sent to a remote island
to
bury the dead
a wisecracking young inmate soon finds
his life in danger
when the island is overrun
by hordes of the undead
who had been killed by prison guards
are there different screenwriting rules
for established screenwriters versus
those that are new writers
i think so i think
i think that there are unwritten rules
um and it just again
i think a lot of it basically boils down
to
like formatting how your script looks
um how you present your script i mean
newbies can't do
what established writers can do
um
you know i mentioned like the robert
town thing or yeah i feel a lot of
screenwriters don't use slug lines at
all for me that's a big thing i i think
that that's that's insane but i know
that william goldman for instance
doesn't use slug lines and of course he
you know butch cassidy and the sundance
kid right
but i feel like
a william goldman can get away with that
j fingers cannot
[Laughter]
so i i'm you know very careful in how i
format and present my work so that one
day if i do decide that i want to break
a rule here there i can
do you have an opinion about log lines
yes
i do not like log lines i
i think log lines suck
what's wrong with them they're they're
just so they're they're difficult
they're difficult you know everyone's
just like oh if you can you know if
you're unable to distill you know your
story into one sentence you can't tell
me in one
maybe two sentences what your script is
about then
then already i know that your script is
terrible and i'm like no that's not true
um
i mean i i do understand the importance
of log lines
uh it's just crafting them is is just a
pain i just don't don't like doing it
um
my log line for potter's field
i worked on
for weeks before i
finally got one that i thought was
was decent
i i can't even say that i was like
like truly pleased with the final
log line but
at you know a certain point i was just
like okay i've got to stop this is this
is where we're at and i'm going to see
if this works and
it's got me some requests so obviously i
did something right with that
so the log line for this film which is
potter's potter's field feel okay it
took you how long
uh several weeks several weeks several
weeks it took me several weeks to craft
this one
but then that's also based on you know
just working on it previously you know
just coming up with log lines that just
absolutely didn't work and just me
giving up or you know like whatever so
what i when i finally came back uh to it
because i i knew that i wanted to start
submitting start getting the script out
there i sat down with with this version
of the log line and yeah it took it took
several weeks for me to craft it and
and
get it into the shape where uh where i'm
finally
getting some some hits from it
oh may we hear it yeah sure
uh sent to a remote island
to
bury the dead
a wisecracking young inmate soon finds
his life in danger
when the island is overrun
by hordes of the undead
who had been killed by prison guards
okay
okay so and that what parts did you
struggle with like where did you
find you well first like
mentioning the protagonist
um
i didn't know how i wanted to
describe him uh there were some drafts
where i used the character's name uh his
name is amir addison but then i realized
no one cares
you know that's not what they're looking
for in a log line you know the
characters they'll get to the
character's name when they read the
script
so in in trying to describe you know who
he was succinctly uh that was that was
difficult for me
uh but then i just thought about
the most striking parts of his
personality you know i mean we already
know that he's you know in prison he's
an inmate
and he has this kind of
uh uh
caustic sense of humor like you know
he's he's always you know just saying
something smart and
you know not really insulting people but
you kind of go in there and so
i thought wisecracking would be a good
way to describe him
and i also wanted to kind of bring the
mind like a young eddie murphy uh you
know we all kind of remember what eddie
murphy was like in his early career you
know with like 48 hours and beverly
hills cop and trading places and i
wanted my character to be reminiscent of
that so i thought that wisecracking was
a great way to kind of describe him
just also just the structure you know
just what should i mention first
you know should i lead off with a
wisecracking young inmate and i did that
for a while but that didn't seem to work
so then i led off with uh you know uh
assigned to
uh bury the dead on this island just it
sets up the the place you know you know
where the script is taking place and
what's supposed to happen and then after
i set it up we mentioned the protagonist
you know
wisecracking young inmate
but i think the thing that really
uh
made the log line work
was at the end i added
a little tidbit about the undead who had
been murdered by prison guards that was
missing
and
everyone you know when i asked for
feedback on the log line they're just
like ah this is cool i guess but you
know how about but when i added that one
part toward the end
response was
it was just like oh wow this is
now i get it you know now i i want to
read this now this is
it hooks me
so that's the log line that i decided to
go out with and yeah once i started
querying
i started getting hits you know i
started getting requests for the for the
split for for the script
so you were sending it out before you
had this particular log line no no i
wasn't sending it out no no uh just
working on the log line so that i could
send it out
uh i see okay so you weren't able to
weigh whether this was was an improved
version but you knew from the reaction
that this tidbit at the end
where we know like why
why these people had died and right okay
exactly interesting wow
and did anyone say it was too long it
was too short of a long time no no um i
don't know how many words it is exactly
but i know i tried to keep it kind of
within the recommended limit you know
like 35 words 35 to 40 words i think is
what they say
your log line you know should be
so i tried to keep it within that
now for your books
the description i know on amazon when i
looked at it it's much longer you know
oh yeah it's like a paragraph or so um
is there something with books where
there's the same type of rules for the
log line
no it's different okay yeah yeah you
know i mean they expect a much uh much
longer
in-depth kind of blurb you know so that
they can put on on the back of books on
amazon and barnes noble
uh press releases what have you yeah
there's log lines are not really
not really a thing at least you know in
my experience yeah in the publishing
kind of like world right so with scripts
short log line and then a lot of white
on the page kind of like get to the
point
and don't race waste the reader's
attention sounds like okay